hey everybody and welcome to a classic
wild ride with stevo we've got jackass
superstar dave england and if you stick
around to the end of the podcast you'll
see him take a [ __ ] on the table in the
tour bus because i asked him to we got
big laughs we have a good time and i
gotta say i look great you know why
because i'm taking care of my skin
with
geology this is a revolution in men's
skin care and they've got 5 000 5 star
reviews they're just
perfect for fighting acne stopping
wrinkles puffiness under the eyes and
i'm telling you no matter what your age
it's never too soon to start taking care
of your skin and if you want a killer
deal on a big time starter kit that's
valued at
50 bucks but you get it for 15
or just up to 70 percent off your 30-day
trial you're gonna go to geology that's
g e o l
o g i e dot com use the promo code stevo
and get your fifty dollar value starter
kit for just 15 bucks and when you get
to the website take their free
two-minute skin quiz to make sure you
get the perfect products for you
take care of your skin do it like a man
and that's at
geology.com with the promo code stevo
now let's get into it
oh okay
right
ladies and gentlemen oh here let's see
what time it okay it's 6 25.
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
dave england
ew the return
i'm back yeah dude i listened to our
first wild ride with dave england today
gotta say it was hilarious
and uh
i'm [ __ ] stoked to have you back yeah
thanks yeah dude i had fun last time
right same that was a good one and part
for the course the the the last time i
just show up for a double date uh
you know with my girl and dave's girl
and i'm just like okay everybody we're
doing a podcast with dave dave didn't
even know that we just ambushed him with
that you tried me he had poison oak
right right one of the last one
yeah yeah yeah i am and now this time
around we're here in
minneapolis we're bringing dave on tour
to
to
perform to as the the warm-up act the
opener it's going to be great he gets
off the airplane he's not even allowed
to put down his suitcase
we're doing a podcast
yup straight to here yeah dude in the
airport i'm stoked wouldn't you have it
any other way
so you're gonna be on tour it's not not
your first time doing stand-up you've
been
yeah i mean i've i don't really call it
stand up because i just tell you know
stories about jackass and stuff i don't
really know how to tell actual jokes
but you told me that you've gone out of
your way to uh develop new material
you've been practicing at open mics yes
yep and it's it's current material oh
yeah just or you know it might be a some
of the materials a story that's a from
the past but i haven't told it right i
can't stand up yet you talk about
getting your dick ripped off or almost
ripped off yeah yeah
4.5
yeah this is the you know one of the
things i want to talk about there is
just how crazy is to have my dick all
over netflix it's super weird
like you're not supposed to get your
dick out at all in public but you know
there's a close-up somebody addicted to
just click on and watch on netflix
right
um
because i think of it as you we were all
wearing
uh like g
g string underwear but to show the
damage that your dick says yeah it came
out pull it out it was out and it was
really like if you had a big screen tv
it'd be about this big right where would
you be would you call that a blood
blister what you hear like all my veins
just turned black and got like like
balls of black you know i guess stopped
up blood or something it looked bad it
looked like something was gonna burst or
my dick would never work again
and it was fine i mean it hurt for a
while but it was fine was that who else
got was it your dick too that got pulled
but
fortunately or not fortunately for me
the the weight of the brick and for
anybody who didn't see jackass 4.5
considering how well it performed i
think everybody did
but this was the first thing we filmed
for jackass forever when we went into
production very first day of like
principal production
the first bit we filmed first thing in
the morning 9 a.m
was that like an ode to the movie old
school where they're standing on a
building and tie
bricks to their wieners they're like
we're gonna do it for real life you know
we're gonna do it for real
i got like okay man here we go
it was funny too because not everybody
some people's ropes were long enough
that it would hit the ground two strings
were too short i didn't even know until
you pointed out i didn't even know that
it was like
that obvious i didn't you said oh hey
you know i wonder who it is and i looked
down like oh man
i didn't even really pay enough
attention i'm not i
i can't remember that well but i think
it was really fairly obvious yeah it won
the video it is when i watched it now i
wonder why they didn't just make
everybody's string too short why save
two people
good point they needed some dicks for
later
right but but uh famously dave only has
one ball
and so
my two balls and shaft were enough to
kind of uh
reinforce the the hold
such that
my brick broke my string
wow did we talk about in the last one
why you only have one ball what happened
to it ah we did talk about it yeah oh
i always had the idea that like the
snowboard like sliced your nutsack and
your ball fell out but in fact
yeah it happens on a mountain somewhere
right now it's just rolling down the
mountain into a snowball and got bigger
and bigger yeah check out our whole
family
taking them out now yeah well yeah i
mean how did danger not lose a testicle
i don't know man i really didn't want to
do that we we couldn't talk about it
last time because we wouldn't come out
but yeah i that still i feel bad about
what i did like i don't think people
like me as much after they saw what i
did because i think you should feel bad
but like just that i agreed to do a real
friend would have said no end of story
i'm not doing it right right i don't
know the pogo stick right on his [ __ ]
nut sack that's pretty rotten i mean
to be fair you were jumping the pogo
stick onto his cup
yeah it was a cup test that that was a
freak accident and could never be
expected but with that said
i
i mean i don't want to like
be disparaging
of jackass but i gotta say that i feel a
little weird about the whole
danger aaron cup test because it
i read a review it was like this is like
dark peer pressure like gone
like really but he chose to do that that
was his idea like he brought that to the
table they weren't like aaron you're
doing this he asked to do that can i ask
how many times did each one bit take
like the hockey player got it right away
or no
first it's pretty much just like it
played out it was like
the one that was disturbing was bowling
because like over and over nope you
gotta do it again
and that ended up in four point five the
bowling yeah he got nailed with that
bowling ball
so many times yeah softball too the
softball was
so gross when it would hit him in the
thigh or the stomach it was just like
the meaty sound of it
he just sounded like it would break his
bone or something but he was going you
know what i i just think that there's
there's just like a weird cut like
number one jackass forever was like
pretty
and we all acknowledged dick heavy like
like trauma to
testicles and penises was like
pretty
overdone
i mean it was it was it was all good
stuff but and then like the the cup test
was just fun even for jackass just felt
kind of too violent
not even the pogo stick only but like
that hot you know it always like that's
one way to look at it i mean again i
mean it got aaron some of the best
footage i mean i know i'm stoked yeah i
know in hindsight aaron's super stoked
because arguably he was like
not super like
recognizable and now he really i think
probably is i told him while we were
filming i was like dude danger you
waited until the fourth movie to become
a star
how long has he had that mohawk like a
good 15 years yeah i don't know wow so
long can i ask about the uh
silence of the lambs bit how long were
you in that room for
i'm not the least bit upset that i was
out of town when they filmed the silence
of the lamb's bit
because i might have [ __ ] myself and if
i did you know i would be racing to the
nearest hello tushy bidet
it's my favorite product that i've ever
promoted on this podcast i cannot stand
pooping without it because it's just
like a pressure cleaner for your
butthole it's so satisfying when you get
done pooping you just twist the dial and
this jet stream of water at you control
the the power of it and you blast it
good and clean and then you wipe your
butt and there's nothing even on the
toilet paper you're only wiping just to
make sure it's dry and now they've got
the tushy ace which is a whole seat
where you can control the temperature
control the temperature of the water you
can
use a remote control to make it work if
you have not tried
hello tushy products you are missing out
and if you want to try them then get 10
off your order by going to
hellotushy.com again i swear by this
product and it is reckless of me to say
they're my favorite product i've ever
promoted on the podcast but i love it
that much so go to
slash
hellotushy.com
and get that 10 percent off now let's
talk about the silence of the lambs
i don't seem like 20 minutes to a half
hour maybe it seemed like or i don't
know for sure but that's what it seemed
like and it was like you were it was
pretty [ __ ] scary right like really
bad yeah the most traumatizing thing i
mean you couldn't see you couldn't see
anything like your hand in front of your
face or what like you might as well not
have eyes for one thing and that's scary
and then and then just like the not
knowing what you're like how far are
these gonna you know these guys are kind
of dumb to our bosses sometimes they'll
take it too far and they don't know i'm
like we're i'm trusting them now to do
something really bad to me that i can't
see right did you believe that there's
actually a rattlesnake there's a i knew
for a fact that that was [ __ ]
there's no way they're gonna risk us
trampling the [ __ ] snake that's what
happens right you know like
he actually [ __ ] stopped his head in
yeah you're not yeah preston was saying
that too he's like i knew it wasn't
gonna be the snake but it's like but it
wasn't even good
right was that the worst bit you've ever
been a part of
it was it was traumatizing and scary as
[ __ ] and yeah i i i mean yeah i guess so
how soon in the filming was did that bit
happen pretty early dude that was the
first week yeah yeah that was the first
week
that was the last thing i remember
driving down the highway with all the
windows rolled down after that going woo
i'm out of there
we did a week of filming and wow because
even though it's so alive and so free
after that i think this was in 4.5 but
after that bit and you're like is it
over like you know like the paranoia of
like
we're done though right like the fact
that that happened so early did that
make like every day on set was like a
little tense like oh [ __ ] i don't know i
try not to think about it that way in
hindsight i'm like i guess i was pretty
like gripped a lot of times but i tried
to just relax and meet every day as just
like okay it's gonna be not that bad i
remember the end of jackass three being
where like tension like that the final
like couple weeks it was just like ah
like it was so much that was your first
sober one too so you were really on it
right looking over your shoulders yeah
you know but like i was super laid back
on on the fourth one like oh you know
what am i gonna get in the way of
getting footage
right exactly the worst day i had
nothing even happened to me it was a
it was the same day we did it
yeah aaron's i did i the same day i pogo
sticks as nuts
in the morning jeff jermaine's like
we're going to have this like the worst
stinging insect sing you in their lips
today i'm like okay and then like the
whole day i thought that up until
5 p.m i'm like when are we going to do
that it's almost the end he's like oh i
didn't tell you that they couldn't find
the bug we're not doing that so the
whole day i literally was getting we
were in this like weird hilly out in
like the malibu hills out there i was
going to run to the road and hitchhike
out of there that's how freaked out i
was i keep making this plan i'm like
i'll just run out there i'll put my
thumb out i'll say just take me anywhere
and i'll get an uber once i can get a
signal and i'll never i'll just tell
them the next day i'm sorry yeah cause i
remember went to the we went to the
hilton to do a the podcast with danger
and then i was in the lobby and then
preston walked down and he like looked
at me he's like
what are you doing here why are you here
and like he was like freaked out that
why would i be there and he thought like
it was some elaborate scheme to get him
like that's how traumatized he was yeah
well and the anticipation too like
that's what knoxville was saying like
for something like a bowl stunt he's
like just make it so when i get there we
shoot it right away i don't want to be
standing there worried about it thinking
about it like yeah knox did look
like uncharacteristically
concerned before that bullet hit whereas
in the past he actually looked forward
to it like and he'd be cracking jokes
the whole time he wasn't he was he was
yeah you could see him thinking about it
it was tough man it was tough and i
remembered when we were filming jackass
number two
he uh there's some like hot potato bit
with uh
uh oh the little guy from the gay guy
from sex in the city yes
that's what they call them i didn't just
make that up they called them there's
like a hot potato bit with the stun gun
and axel just didn't like it he's like i
don't he's he's like dude i don't like
electricity bulls i and i can't wait to
get in front of the next bullet i just
don't want you know
and and i thought like oh okay come on
you know but then sure enough he gets to
the bullring and he's just yeah
great mood
like i don't get it the time i think the
opener for jackass too he was inside the
house and he did it like three or four
times where a whole stampede of him
would come through and just
and he there was like a
this high of a window bottom that it
would just hit him in the legs and then
they'd yeah
yeah said it again again again and each
time it looked like he died i just how
do you go yeah i need to do that again
like right you narrowly escape death all
these heavy bowls of wood you know thou
over a thousand pounds right some of
those things
how does he not get completely broken up
i mean he did but yeah i i have no idea
he had a brain bleeding the concussion
in the [ __ ] my only guess is that
growing up in knoxville tennessee
that
there's like
you know rodeo is a thing and like the
like the definition of like manliness is
riding bulls being in the ring with
bulls and so to knock so that's like the
highest
standard of manliness and so like he
just
puts so much equity like so much
value in that and that's what he wants
like that's his highest goal it's also
great footage whereas like electrocution
right it's always like it you don't even
hear like you have to put in a sound
effect for the people that know that it
even happened like it's less of a visual
so i get also why did not like what's
the point of the electrocution it sucks
and it's not great footage
you said before that you were
heartbroken that uh that you didn't
take a [ __ ] in uh
the last two
i've taken
shits and everything taking
three shifts and three number one movies
i think that i blew my line i've i've
taken two i'm blowing it i hope i don't
do this on stage ah okay i've taken
three number twos and three number one
movies okay
so uh to have this next movie where i
just didn't do it at all i mean i had
that toilet geyser thing and i was
trying every time but man with that
thing flying up there it was hard how
gnarly was that
i had black and blue thighs you know
behind my thighs but um it's pretty
intense like yeah and like you really
had to protect your junk because it was
just like that right you sit on a clear
plexiglas thing and that thing just
just kicked so hard
it was pneumatic pressure it wasn't the
water so much they had like air pressure
and tremaine just kept saying up it up
the pressure up the pressure but by the
end you know it was blowing me sky high
so you were sitting on a like a
plexiglass seat yeah it's clear and so
like it was actually uh like uh yeah so
the water wasn't hitting me it was
actually uh hitting up that water and
the air would just
force up against this plate that would
that was on a small chain so it wouldn't
follow me up also so you know they were
afraid it would follow me up and hit me
on the edge really heavy or hit someone
else in there and it looks so good
thanks but yeah we we practiced it
uh one day for i don't know maybe ten
times and got it dialed then on the day
i think we did it eight times
wow
yeah the reactions were so great you
know like for for what i was saying i
was i was sounding critical of of the
movie let's also be clear that it was a
critical darling isn't that crazy like i
know what yeah i know at first i'm like
what's a critical darling yeah
whatever and we just took that in our
stride we were like well yeah of course
the greats don't love it this time
around like 87
fresh
i know i caught
the world needed
yeah what do you think is the reason for
that well there was covid that you know
people ready to just forget about all
the problems yeah and then uh
and then also just the
longevity of our friendships and
everything and just
to see that we've been doing this for so
many years that
it stokes people out i think
yeah was there any bits that you backed
out of in the new one
um i can't think of anything i don't
think so is there any do you regret
backing out of that bit where they shot
the bullets at you and the oh not in
this way you mean then number two yeah
oh no we talked about the sketchy as
hell those people i think they got
busted for like meth or something
finally i hope i'm not talking [ __ ]
about something something that didn't
happen but i'm pretty sure those people
are shady they were they have weapons
they're going to come after me now what
am i doing
god damn it i don't know what you're
talking about yeah we're good we just
made it up anyway
yeah well we had to do that it was like
this riot control thing yeah like they
put it out on an election
blast i do not regret backing out that
yeah you made that even ryan came up to
me he's like that you're smart that
sucked yeah and bam cried yeah
they told they told us it wouldn't break
the skin and they were all just bleeding
like out of everywhere after that yeah
[ __ ]
um did you not even write any [ __ ]
bits for the new movie yeah i did
i wrote one that i really wanted to do
too i think dave england's about to
cough up an idea he wrote for jackass
and that gets me excited does it get you
excited does it make you hard as a rock
well i'll tell you what's definitely
going to make you hard as a rock and
that's blue chew tablets baby they're
these awesome chewable tablets delicious
i might add and they have the same exact
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except they only cost a fraction of the
price and if you're wondering if it's
true do they really give you a raging
boner and make having sex way more fun
the answer is yes
that's why i swear by it and that's why
i promote it and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for free all you
gotta pay is five bucks for shipping
that's at
bluechew.com with the promo code stevo
and to get these tablets it's so easy
you consult with one of their medical
providers online for your prescription
get on this go to bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo get an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets and
enjoy a raging boner and
have
sex
yeah dude all right so one more time
bluetooth.com use the promo code steebo
now let's get this idea
have a swing
with a toilet seat and then you know
that trick you do on a swing we swing as
high as you can then you do a flip out
of it and at the height of my flip i was
gonna [ __ ] upside down
that's epic yeah and it's simple you
know and they you think that we could oh
yeah we'll just shoot that real quick it
won't take very much but they never did
it
i wrote some other ones too that was the
one i really wanted though but yeah i
wrote some and just didn't happen i mean
we know we had so few filming days for
this one compared to any of the other
ones it was like 30 days of filming
and no travel all in and around la only
so there are a lot of ideas that didn't
happen
yeah seriously right especially ones
that you were like planning to do was
there a trip that was planted like
international they were never gonna they
were never gonna challenge before that's
because of kovid yeah he had fused what
i'm saying like even when they're when
you're writing the movie before covet
hit there was no like and then we'll go
fly to india
he said if you if you guys want to go
somewhere write enough ideas that are
good to make us want to take you there
yeah so i would always said that yeah
i've always tried you know i want to go
somewhere i'm like yeah i write a bunch
of new zealand ideas uh-huh you know but
um
you uh
that was it that just the one swinging
[ __ ] idea no i had a bunch of ideas but
i'm not just gonna blur them all out
here for everybody i feel like that
one's a goner now
but yeah
i don't know if they just didn't want a
[ __ ] in this movie they got preston [ __ ]
in the movie um yeah
accidentally
man that stunk i was like a hundred
yards away i was so far away i'm like
what is that smell like oh look in there
preston [ __ ] his pants i was nowhere
near and i could smell it wow somebody
said uh
god preston had been so bummed about
like that happening i'm like what about
getting that epic gold footage yeah i'm
like i'm like dude like he was about to
do some dirty dancing thing where like
he could get hurt and like
and he didn't have to get hurt he got
the footage like he's stoked for sure
it's hilarious part of the movie
yeah though you think he was about to
get hurt
i mean whatever like it would like it
i bet we man what was yeah
i mean we man
just like got out of any pain
right he just
and we were nowhere near any place to
clean up though either that's another
problem i don't know how we got that all
cleaned up but yeah so there being less
filming days did you guys feel
pressure
or like a different kind of pressure
during this movie i mean when you're
filming a movie you're always we're
trying to get footage trying and do this
but like did you feel like oh [ __ ] i
don't know did it feel like more
pressure knowing that you had less days
to get it all i don't even think that we
were aware that there were less days it
was just in fact like wow
we're done you know like
and and i think that
pretty much everything we did worked you
know to some degree i mean 4.5 is a
badass for a 0.5 yeah you know
yeah i love it i love that it was kind
of like
because they're not always like
documentary style like that right it was
different than most of the 0.5
to a degree but this one had like more
of a story to tell you know like about
coming out after 10 coming back 10 years
later with the kovid like yeah that
really it lent itself to having a
narrative yeah i liked it how did you
like your bit with the the eagle taking
off your eyebrows did you like how that
came out on camera it's so hard to not
react on a phantom camera like with my
eyes oh right yeah
camera you're like don't i'm not gonna
flinch or anything no you could try so
hard to not flinch but that really
beyond your control but then after it
pulls away and you're like
so funny in real life it was so rad too
it's just so cartoonish and looking back
on the podcast that's why you had the
bandana on all those videos yeah people
are always like why is this guy wearing
a bandana because i was right in the
middle of filming and then you had that
little bandana you look like jeff what
was his name love jeff love the guy from
tiger king yeah we kept calling you jeff
love
yeah
yeah steve lowe steve yeah
yeah
yeah dude so uh so what's my what have
you been up to since the movie came out
um i just been kind of just surfing and
hanging out in i i just live in a little
town there just
not a real go-getter like you
man it's great like
it's crazy to me to think that like with
uh
you know with the whole moment of like a
movie coming out like you want to like
just scramble to
take advantage of the i want to but
um that would cut into like my weed
smoking time
just can't pencil it in um what about
like uh making content because i
maintain i said it on the last one i'll
say it again i i feel that you are
the most creative guy uh you know like
you're i love your your
[ __ ] mind your ideas like the whole
thing and and i think it's such a
just a
tragedy for the world at large that
you're not
cranking out content on a youtube
channel yeah i don't know just the whole
thing seems like
like a lot of work for
i don't know what i don't even
understand
it it's a lot of work yeah that's for
sure but i think that if if anybody's
suited to just have like dope ass
content
you know i've been pushing for pontius
to do it
and uh yeah i mean you have to like
start with build up your whole thing
like but here's the thing dude i've been
going for like the last decade building
up
my thing and so then if you and i make a
video together and at the end of the
video i'm like dave's got a channel
click here watch his video and subscribe
to his channel then i basically i'm
going to take all of my audience and
just hand them to you they're going to
leave you they're going to unsubscribe
unsubscribe from you and stick with me i
don't i might be devo [ __ ] it
i don't um
know if that uh is a concern but but
whatever you know like i'm just kidding
i work on on uh
it's not my nature but on
having an attitude of abundance where
there's enough to go around and i can
help other people to try to lift up
other people and make them successful
and not feel threatened that they're
gonna take food off my table
like uh you know and i encouraged all my
people to
put more
joyful content out into the world
well if between movies you're i mean
you're not the go-getter steve is is
there any
and like you know ambitions that you
have that you're trying to like he loves
his chickens and his wife yeah you got
your chickens and that'll work
yeah
yeah
like i mean
yeah i mean i make little silly things
here and there and i do things right i
think i just don't know i guess rattle
them off for you
when you got on cameo like you were
putting so much that was fun yeah
instead of like because everyone else
was like doing a quick thing getting
doing a bunch of them at once i was like
each one of these i'm going to make like
it's my own little video and it was fun
but then one day i woke up like man i'm
spending way too much time making like
25 bucks for videos or something i uh
felt the same way man i cared so much
about making each cameo so epic
and uh
this is too much man yeah
um
i'm gonna cop up an idea right here that
uh i probably shouldn't and maybe we can
do this uh do this together but
knoxville did the cameo where he he was
trying to trick me oh yeah and he put it
as like dave and jason jason dave and
the boys yeah that makes it sound like i
was involved
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind it in the
slightest my only uh
you know
my only thought on all that is that he
didn't get me that good you know i mean
granted i quit before they could really
ramp it up you know dude i remember we
were in philly and you came out to the
car in the morning and you were so
bummed on this guy that gave you
three-star reviews
you were like that is amazing my story
that wasn't that he did a good job
pranking but that your reaction to it
was so severe like broke you quit
for sure
if you if you wanted to just give me a
five star review and said but can you
read it again i would have been like
[ __ ] yeah no problem for sure
you're like i care about what i do man
like let's fix that review yeah
you didn't sleep that night i'm just a
psycho i saw some really negative
comments too on uh
like the youtube video or something this
just shows who you are you know like you
actually thought it was a fan and
they're three starting you quit and you
give up on your fans i'm like no
again
like whatever i i don't even i don't
even care but what what i was getting at
is that um i think that there's
something really fun there and like
getting
uh
celebrities
who are on cameo to say funny things
that are like
me you know like and and i want to make
a whole video like prank cameo prank
kinda yeah cameo pranks where's just
buying cameos from
right celebrating but
if you go to the website of cameo then
the whole website is is effectively like
a menu and everybody sets their own
price for for what they want to charge
for their their shout out caitlyn
jenner's number one for like two grand a
post or something like that ah that it's
kind of there's got to be higher than
than that but uh
but um so we we one time we were on a
road trip and i was going through cameo
and just saying the names of the people
and then it was like a price is right
you know everybody guesses how much they
charge which was a really fun game to
play and um and then now i think after
the knoxville video
to go through the all the the roster on
the cameo website and just come up with
different ideas like for this person
it'd be really funny to get them to say
so and so
like uh
the one idea i had was like i know that
the guy uh chris hansen from to catch a
predator
is on there like if you could just have
them say like it takes one to no one
you know yeah you could just yeah
carefully
orchestrate it to where anyone say what
you want and then put them all together
and you make like some crazy videos or
right um and i is no protection against
that
i i don't know i think you're allowed to
read those cameras i think the whole
point is that you're making a video you
can put them on your social media right
there's a description unless you're
trying to abuse it though there's a
discrepancy if um you're
using it to promote your business but in
this case you wouldn't be at all you
know some people have agreed to that
there's a box you can click i agree to
well right right
i don't want those you actually you
actually set a price for a personal one
and then one for endorsing a business
yeah which is just insane
but uh but maybe we could do that and i
don't want to like be like
mean-spirited or bum anybody out of
course you know that's never the idea
but uh i also wanted to be hilarious
but people have gotten like really good
deals on like a local business that
wants like a radio commercial just have
someone do the cameos they like come
down to my car wash and yada yada yada
right and the celebrities did it for a
couple hundred bucks and then there's a
commercial
i'm surprised people charge so little on
like that i don't know i was i'm always
shocked
at the number being so low for well they
say start low and then you know you
build it up work up yeah so because
you're at twenty five dollars a video
it's like or something like that yeah
and then they take a cut
you're not on there anymore no i got off
there after i was like i wasn't gonna
just start making the ones where i was
gonna rattle through them i was only
gonna make the ones that i put too much
effort into which wouldn't be worth it
so
it's so crazy man the people who like
put no effort at all
yeah they just read it just hold the
phone here and read hey and then there's
reading exactly and they have five star
yeah
like band margera's five stars [ __ ]
unblemished yeah
how much does he charge
i'm not even sure 100 bucks pretty
reasonable
yeah
people are stoked you know they get
that's like someone they look up to and
they're like idle and it's just like hey
here's a personalized message right to
you that's worth 100 bucks sure it
doesn't have to be long this has to be
this one-handed thing well it's usually
something you're going to send like a
buddy you know so like yeah your buddy's
a big bam fan so you haven't recorded
this thing
yeah
but i like your idea but i just wonder
if there's already something set in
place to prevent that because
right you should get on it before they
do prevent it yeah i don't think that
there is and maybe uh
we should [ __ ] hurry up and fire up
the cameo website
let's do it
maybe even doing the most expensive ones
because those are ones that like just
the average person isn't getting you
know like right so like
i kind of remember something like that
snoop dogg was 420 it was like 420 bucks
it's good i don't know if he kept that
price but i i think he was on for like
24 hours oh it was like a thing
god they're tireless too they uh yeah
they're always hitting me back up yeah
you don't want to get back on here
there's so much money to be made we're
rolling around in
money
rules caitlyn jenner's 2500.
that's the highest one that
how long of a video do you get there's
no association
here's the top ten floyd met mayweather
999 dollars
barbara corcoran 999 dollars oh she's
from shark tank yeah shark tank louis
anderson a thousand
tony allen a thousand
louie anderson's passed away yeah uh
he's still doing cameos angela simmons a
thousand did you guys watch baskets oh
man
galloping
anderson and who else a bunch of awesome
people are in that it's really good
yeah louie anderson was like stole the
show no he was mrs buckets yeah
he's got yeah that show had like dark
moments too they were so well done there
was like that easter brunch or whatever
and louie anderson
was heavy yeah it was yeah you gotta
watch that yeah
um
so
how many chickens do you have
i think there's like 16 of them out
there something like that and you have a
rooster yeah this morning i had to get
up early for this flight so you know the
whole rest of the house is asleep i
turned one little light on at 5 00 a.m
[Music]
all the way till when i left them
because is that because he does that to
protect
apparently yeah but he's [ __ ]
protecting way too much all day every
day all ever from the first light that
comes on in the house all the way until
i didn't know that it was reactive
sometimes in the middle of night
for no reason
definitely there is a reason yeah that's
reacting to something yeah well don't
they usually do it when the sun comes up
like maybe i thought it was the same
yeah that and then everything else too
just everything so if you sneak up on it
in the middle of the day you don't have
to sneak up on it but if i mock him if i
do a cock-a-doodle-doo he'll he'll go oh
yeah and then he'll do this oh yeah
and uh you know
people generally don't want to have
roosters because they make so much noise
so
so they'll kill all the male chickens
but keep all the female chickens
and if you do that and you don't have a
rooster isn't it cruel
i mean you know they protect the flock
and yeah and it's like
i do he just seriously he just plows all
those other chickens
all day long oh yeah that is rough too
like it sounds like something's
attacking the chickens i'm like oh it's
just
doug the rooster protector he's a real
polygamist
yeah living the dream
barely does anything i'll just get a
fake one it's like just as good
i've got a few i don't have to make
salads all the time for it yeah that's
smart kids can ride it and [ __ ] and sit
there
you have like a giant bunny though right
two giant bunnies flemish giant flowers
it looks like it's i'm afraid of the
bunnies their legs are so they'll kick
you they can rip your gut open they're
horrible
if they wanted to be mean it could be
real bad
um
and just just moves the one dog and
amazing well that's right you got
amazing now yeah
yeah amazing she's kind of a spaz and
she's only a year old we've had her
since she was a little puppy is it hard
to convince the dogs to not eat the
chickens no they protect them oh wow
nice that's rad and uh and you have cats
one cat one cat all right we used to
have two cats but something happened to
one and your kids are [ __ ] maniacs
and maniac kids yep
how uh
the youngest was like dropping in on a
quarter pipe yeah we talked about that
last time um
how much does being a dad with your
like maniac kids
like
uh prevent you from pursuing like
different stuff that you might want to
do i don't know i could blame everything
on them huh yeah it's all their fault
that's why i haven't been making my own
youtube channel yeah there's
there's there's little freeloading
[ __ ]
losers
hijacking dave's careers
taking all his energy yeah all of his
careers love his ambition
siphoned away by those little bastards
exactly because yeah i don't know that i
don't blame them i can still probably do
it pull off whatever i should some
people put their kids to work put them
on youtube i did that once in my two
older kids one time only that where i
was doing it was kind of like an idea
was like you know aaron got the tooth
pulled out by the lamborghini this was a
like a little mini motorcycle i remember
my daughter
pulled it you know the tooth out the
loose tooth out of um my son what was
that what was the uh
wave pulling the tooth
wave no what was the way oh it was a
little mini motorcycle motorcycle yeah
so my daughter was on that but the funny
part was when she was tying the string
on his tooth and he's complaining about
her bad breath and everything so it went
viral and got you know millions of views
and then uh on what platform on youtube
i'm like wow
and i didn't put it on my channel back
then i put it on youtube for just my
family to see and then uh all these tv
stations wanted to use it and my kids
had all got all this money out of it and
oh yeah then i was like that's it i'm
gonna do i don't want to put them in the
spotlight when they're kids i just want
them to be children i enjoy being kids
you know when was that
2011. so you have a you have a youtube
channel right after the movie came out
so jackass 3 came out with aaron getting
his tooth ripped out in 2010 so this is
2011.
so how many subscribers did your channel
get i don't remember that one that was
just like the kids channel they had
their own channel with just some well
we're gonna take that but now i have now
i have like one i wonder my name that
i've only put one thing at one of the
australian jackass tours
is on there that's the only video i've
ever put up i've been a little cut and
made of our trip that's the only thing
i've read let's get organized man all
right you guys help me if you guys will
help me i have all these ideas written
out we just gotta dude
i'm not good at the follow-through
that's not true
while you're on tour for the for this
next week we'll make one video for my
channel one video for your channel all
right we'll drive all my traffic to
yours
how can i say no to that that's the
[ __ ] yeah i love it i would love to
give you my whole audience
as much of it as i possibly can i'm
getting pranked
i'm not even on cameo i'm getting
[ __ ] praised
not not even um
yeah dude
have fun
or not fun
is the uh the this this text thread that
we have with the entire jackass entire
jackass cast i guess no entire jackass
left the conversation or whatever it
said you know and that's it
every now and then i'll tell them what's
going on on there
oh yeah you should be on that i'm like
you want me to add you no no no no like
i'll add you no no no
wow that's great some people just hate
group messages yeah you're just getting
yourself up against anybody he just
doesn't like yeah i thought that he was
on it but just that
watching silently
when i saw preston uh not long ago i was
like man like what's going on with the
man he feels like he's kind of uh quiet
he's distancing himself alienated you
know and just because he's not on
wow man that's crazy but it's all the
new people too
it's everybody
not spike jones now i learned not we man
but knoxville tremaine like poopies
rachel wolfson
he's pretty active like i don't know if
eric is still on there because he went
back to the uk
sure he used to chime in and now yeah
even isn't dark shark on there and i
don't think dark sharks on there is he i
think there was because there was like
they were right when they were beating
up everybody about getting uh vaccines
wasn't that the thread
oh i think that that was on poopies they
were doing that too
i don't think he's on the threat i'm
pretty sure okay i'll check but in any
case he'd be writing some all the time
he's pretty vocal right
in any case i'm uh
i'm a person who hates group [ __ ]
text threads just [ __ ] leave me like
but the jackass one i don't mind it and
and god the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ]
there's the
the funny and you're so creative in
there
oh yeah sometimes i just get crickets
i'm like oh i'm [ __ ] pissed
there's also different text threads
there's the one with everybody including
the new cast there's one with just the
og
cast yeah and uh you talk [ __ ] about the
new people
yeah
we don't have anything yeah i'm just
teasing
we are
but but yeah
i guess there's just like all these
different but what do you mean you don't
like text
groups you have a bunch like we have we
have well yeah but that's like work
related okay you know and i'm inundating
you guys so you're the ones hating it
correct you know i consider those like
professional think tanks okay where i'm
like okay everybody like here's a new
draft of the video okay everybody what
do you think about this thumbnail like
okay everybody like right what am i
going to call this it's productive yeah
yeah like it's it's we get a couple of
those on the jackass thread you're like
check out these thumbnails which of
these three do you like yeah yeah for
each i love getting feedback for [ __ ]
i'm gonna put out
yeah it's smart yeah
and and i wish i had a way to have
bigger think tanks too so when you just
send us some a video before you put it
out and then so it's not public you can
just see when each one of us watch it
i can see when someone has oh it doesn't
say who watched it 14 view because i'll
look it'll be like 14 views i'm like can
you see who those are does he know i
just watched this i i can't see
individually who but i can be like man
there's 13 people on this text thread
and it got two views
nobody gives a [ __ ] about my [ __ ] like
ten thumbs ups and like two views well
you gotta find like 10 minutes to sit
down and watch it right right of course
and i'm never butt hurt about that
that's that's perfectly you know
you know social media stuff i'm always
like not sure what people can see if i
look at someone's profile like do they
know that like if i look at their
message do they know that like you have
to tiptoe around you're like ah
right is there a way i just want to
creep around here sure
like if you're like looking deep in
someone's instagram you're like so
careful not to like a photo it's like
you're defusing a bomb yeah like if
you're like a photo that's four years
old you're gonna look like a rush like a
feeling again yeah i'm so careful if i'm
going back yeah
it's creepy
it's it's [ __ ] fantastic dude
so so where where have you been
practicing your uh your new material
i don't really call surfing practicing i
just go surf no no
oh i just went to i went down to la it's
like an hour 15 minute drive from my
house
um rachel wolfson and her boyfriend matt
they they're avid stand-up comedy thanks
for that
they know
and they took me this place and it was
like described to me it's like a gym for
people that do the stand up it's just
the other people doing stand up
looking at their nose barely listening
to you like are you even what's it
called it's called an open mic
um flashback oh okay i think it had two
names had flashback was the name of the
actual shop and then the
stand-up mic thing the open mic had
another name
anyways though it was just like a 12
people or something and i just practiced
kind of like some ideas what i might do
at
the
warm up for your show it's good man like
uh
i told one radio station that you're
gonna be there just because they asked
like are there gonna be any other people
and i was like man i'm not really like
[ __ ] should i have not written that
yesterday
wait was
we could like promote it and promote it
and still when you walk out on stage
it's going to be a surprise
you know it's going to be rad are you
nervous at all
i mean not right now the second but i'm
sure i will be right before i walk out
in the stage but you know what i just
always remember is that you know they're
they're usually and they're definitely
stevo fans but most of them seem to be
jackass fans too sure i mean of course
it kind of goes hand in hand so it is
one in the same i couldn't imagine
walking out low if i wasn't on jackass
and i didn't the people were just like
there's some dude i'd be like oh
somebody won't listen to me paul doesn't
have [ __ ] everything yeah so you know
a lot of people know who you are from
the from the podcast and stuff
some people do yeah but it's like
it's still easier than like just going
up at the comedy store and be like
here's another comic and if that was me
like that that would be scarier the
opening for steve is like no matter how
good or bad my set goes at the end i'm
going to say so you guys excited for
steve oh yeah
yeah it's pretty easy yeah you were
telling me a funny story on the way here
about acapulco
uh when i took the valium before going
on stage yeah did we talk about the last
podcast that we did not talk about oh my
gosh
like you know you would bring different
people along on the stevoir don't try
this at home yeah i think what was it
2003 2004 something from the book yeah i
uh in my new book i i talked about back
then about how uh
you i was such a [ __ ]
um
raging [ __ ] and [ __ ] just
difficult to typically that you quit the
don't try this at home tour and then we
had to replace you with a [ __ ] like
12 foot long king cobra
i didn't only quit i convinced preston
to quit i took him with me too
this is what happened though okay so we
it was it was going pretty good we went
to a bunch of different shows just being
president lacy and you and like nick
dunlap and stuff or dumbledore whatever
it was and then so
so uh we went to cancun went pretty well
and then the next night was acapulco and
then we're in the back room and you're
like
hey you guys need to kind of carry the
show tonight we're like ha ha ha no you
really do we're like why
i took a bunch of volume valium or xanax
or something like if you used them all
out of it and then you went up there and
you started you first you said we're in
acapulco and you're like hello cancun
and then they all started throwing
bottles at us and like they obviously
they're not even from they're just
vacationing you know what i don't um
i
don't think that i had the foresight to
say that you guys needed to carry the
show because yeah i remember and then i
thought you were joking we're like huh
i mean whatever i remember like that was
the only
show out of all of them
maybe there were two when i was on pcp
was one but uh just where the crowd was
just booing like this is [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] and mind you the show itself
was boo worthy at all times
you know yeah but this night you just
got out there and you first said hello
cancun they didn't like that because
they were an acapulco
i swear there's 8 000 people there it
was just like a sea of people
and then you just did this 10 minute
long i think it's called a diatribe
about your dad like these college kids
did not want to hear that [ __ ] at all
what's another tribe diatribe is like a
monologue
droning
just about it's about your dad just
right i can't remember he can't remember
he was so out of it and then like it was
just hell for us and then
later that night i'm like let's go let's
just like go and so we like we're in
acapulco we got a flight to
to uh mexico city and then you know
mexico city airport is huge who do we
see stevo and then the rest of the crew
they're like there they are and i start
running
president came out running so i just
ditched preston and i don't know i think
he still you guys tried to convince him
to come back and he still didn't come
either but this must have been like the
final straw
yeah or was it just this one show that
you're like forget it he got his
bluetooth whatever you've been to like
five or six of them i was already kind
of burned out and i was like okay that's
great
like the way i remember it i was just
kind of a insufferable [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like it was just enough like
you're still pretty funny though i
remember you guys bought that taxi cab
remember that maybe i thought you're
gonna say you're still pretty much for
nationals
you're still pretty insufferable
i remember being entertained like you're
doing funny [ __ ] the whole time and like
we bought a taxi cab and i forget i
don't know that we ever even filmed
anything with it we we brought the
[ __ ]
the king cobra like we had like king
cobra putt-putt we just [ __ ] had him
on the putt-putt we would [ __ ] bring
we brought this king cobra with david
weathers
and and we were in like no seats
standing room nightclubs everybody's
packed up against the stage
and we're [ __ ] releasing a 12 foot
long king cobra that's not in any way
de-venomized it has its fangs it can
kill a [ __ ] elephant and like david
weathers is going to kiss the [ __ ]
thing on the head where there's all
kinds of opportunity for the snake to
[ __ ] bite david weathers or whatever
anything can happen anything happens
david weathers nobody else is even
remotely [ __ ] qualified or able to
wrangle this [ __ ] thing and it's
loose and that it was the most reckless
[ __ ] thing
we just
night after night we just [ __ ]
released the king cobra on [ __ ] stage
in these [ __ ] tiny little night clubs
jeez
you have footage of that yeah for sure
yeah just go back and forth on the stage
it was crazy well mayhem i remember this
one show though in london did i tell the
story of the last
word the latter you're like what do you
want to do i'm like i don't know i'm
like
there's a ladder
yeah there's like a ladder i'm like i'll
climb to the top of the ladder and put a
little cup and i'll [ __ ] into the cup
and you're like okay go for it and i i
go out there do it it lands perfectly in
the cup i'm like yeah and right when i'm
like putting my arms up to celebrate
ryan knocked the ladder out from under
me and i went why am
another time i remember you were puking
on the stage and i was like running
across the stage and i slipped in your
puke and hit my head right in the puke
like like not on my head that covered in
puke do you remember what city that was
no no it was somewhere down south i
think pensacola is my guess i've
definitely seen the footage of
you on the ladder taking the [ __ ] that's
a fun video i don't know did you only do
it one time
okay yeah it was in london yeah in
london
[ __ ] what was it was it called the odeon
or
i feel like there's something there's
like peabody or like some kind of a nah
peabody was in ohio but but whatever
yeah dude like was like i had to come up
with uh
releasing the king cobra on stage and
and dave england i mean that tour looks
nuts hey the fact that nobody died a
miracle that you guys didn't get sued
while don is like choking kids out on
stage and like you guys are people
getting kicked in the balls like people
are beating themselves up right this is
[ __ ] gnarly it was a darling
tour it's some of the crazy
everything that it lacked in uh
like thoughtfulness and organization
you know like
it made up for and just sheer reckless
insanity for sure yeah which is what
people want i mean the audiences are
always stoked i guess except for in
acapulco
yeah yeah now it's like the even more
reckless insanity but that's like
carefully organized and videotaped and
presented on the screen
yeah and it's actually the rest is
actually thoughtful
in any case it's getting kind of [ __ ]
hot in here i say we [ __ ] wrap it up
dude what uh dude mike tyson said this
to me he said
i was on his podcast he said there's
millions of people watching what do you
want to say to them
oh [ __ ] that
pass
make it a puff puff pass maybe
all right well dude [ __ ] i'm so
stoked you're here and thank you stoked
to be here it's gonna be good we're
gonna put this we're gonna put this
podcast out next which means that uh
you'll still be on the road when it
comes out so then what cities you got
coming up with dave on there so people
can go see them oh [ __ ] that's gonna be
after this release yeah we got duluth
tonight's
we got minnesota duluth minneapolis
duluth yeah this will come out
[ __ ] two days
sioux falls lincoln nebraska and fargo
north dakota
but isn't fargo i think everything's
pretty sold out fargo yeah well
he's gonna be stoked for
doing packed [ __ ] houses in like big
theaters that are [ __ ]
going off
dave's starting the show he's the first
thing that happens he's kind of [ __ ] on
stage every show yeah you're going to
[ __ ]
every time yeah
i'm tempted to this is a [ __ ]
terrible idea but listening to the first
podcast
um
dave said he can [ __ ] any time
whenever
and i kind of want
shoot [ __ ] right now [ __ ] on the table
right now yeah i'll clean it up oh no
i'm gonna do that why because this is
not cool
it's very cool not [ __ ] in jackass
forever this is your choice
cool tour bus so the last year
outside and [ __ ] and then the people can
fall down the table what are you worried
about yo why why would you want me to
sit on your table because i feel like
aaron with the pogo stick because
there's a horrible idea you're like i
really want this
i like it i want it
i don't want it wendy's
you face that camera with your butthole
what right there on the table going on
here you really want me to do this i say
[ __ ] on the table don't even know if i
can and
you don't give me something to pee so
the pee doesn't get everywhere
that's a good question i feel like i'm
uncomfortable no i just feel bad already
i'm already feeling bad i don't feel bad
yeah i'll get out of here for that one
gonna hold me oh no don't sit on it like
like like a squat above it stand on the
thing put your butt over here your back
your knees right there let me plan
something for the pee
what's uncomfortable is how excited paul
is for this
let me get something for the feed you're
gonna you need the this is gonna be a
hot clip all right hey paul do you want
that uh boner hider pillow
i'm just letting it out dude yeah yeah
that'd be a good product the pillow just
for hiding your boner
how much people you got is that how you
start the thing is it that whole this
whole thing rattle from him shutting
that
oh that was a weird coincidence right
when you shut that
i mean does a red solo cup do it i'll
just try to go pee first
it's awesome
just keep it on the table that's my oh
god i think you can manage that you got
into a cup
wow paul's really looking down main
street
you got a dangler
look at that like a terrier [ __ ] it's a
cute
oh
all right
all right that didn't take long i did it
yeah it was pretty immediate yeah like
you weren't dead you're a man of your
word dave england and uh and thank you
for doing this
bro correct get over here on camera give
me a hug
yeah bro
i'm waiting for you oh yeah dear i love
you how cute was that little thing
everything this is adorable
dad
i love dave england i genuinely love him
like a brother man and uh
here we are at the skate park where i'm
just getting beat up trying this trick
it's gnarly
so i'm gonna pull it right [ __ ] now
okay you know what you film it